the overall layout of your page should
look fine right now but it doesn't quite
look right for starters we don't
actually have images here of course you
could use the images that are in the
design mock-up but that doesn't make
much sense because those aren't images
of your actual projects in situations
like this it makes sense to have some
type of placeholder image right here we
have placeholder images that simply show
how large they are right now I'm using
place hold it which is an awesome
website that makes really fast and easy
placeholder images each image simply has
its dimensions printed inside it to use
images from place hold it simply follow
the pattern here it's just an image that
starts with place hold it
slash and then the dimensions inside the
source code for the website we can see a
lot of links using place hold on it
let's see if it works
I'm gonna change this image from 960 by
350 to 1,000 by 350 and I will save it
so when i refresh the page we should see
that this turns into a thousand by 350
and there we go the image is a little
bit larger of course these are pretty
boring and it's important to have fun
while you're working so instead of using
place hold at it there are other
services place puppy dot it is an even
more fun way of including placeholder
images look at those cute dogs oh my god
they're so cute yeah anyways you can use
place puppy it slash the dimensions here
and you can also include these in the
page let's give one a shot we'll come
back to here and instead of place hold
on it let's make it place puppy dot it
and 1000 by 350 and we'll save it and
let's come back to our demo and when we
hit refresh we have the top of a
dachshund staring at us and it's
adorable
so that's another way of making your
life a little bit more fun but for those
of you who aren't dog lovers there's
also kittens adding cats to the website
is as easy as using place kitten comm
and it follows pretty similar syntax to
place puppy dot it cats make me allergic
so I'm not gonna use them but you don't
tell you what let's try one out alright
so place kitten comm slash the
dimensions so let's instead of placed
puppy let's make it place kitten com
they have place kitten comm instead of
place puppy got it and we have the same
dimensions and when we refresh the page
now we have an adorable cat staring at
us so you've got options for making your
life a lot more fun when you're building
websites which of the following
placeholder images do you prefer using
none because using the real images is
probably the best strategy or do you
like using place hold on it because sing
dimensions is really helpful
do you like place puppy dot it because
seeing dogs just makes your day better
or do you think that kittens with place
kitten calm is the way to go if none of
these type your answer in here and let
us know which one you like using